hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are at Round four
with the second pair of the of the
players on issue with the white piece
against England this is the first match
we're going to cover and the Giri is so
far without a single game won in this
tournament so maybe ding will be at the
unlucky character or or the victim f4
Giri so without further ado let's check
it out it's it's quite the theoretical
struggle yeah so d4 by giri tonight of 6
c4 and the g6 we have the Kings Indian
defense Knight c3 and now transposing
into the groom field we have d5 and C
capture Sun d5 just going for the the
classical way Knight captures efore
Knight captures and c3b captures and
Bishop to g7 so this is all very
standard stuff Bishop to c4 and now c5
attacking white strong Center we have
Knight to e2 defending in Knight to c6
again attacking with Bishop to e3
defending and both players just Castle
here and sorry tie both players just
castle here and now b6 again this is all
very standard and here rook the c1 we
rush up the b7 developing the light
square bishop and then now comes the
Bishop to b5 making it hard for for
black to develop the rook if you if you
go here then d5 comes and also as a
black will probably capture once on d4
you will already have two of your pieces
attacking the knight here so here we
have a trade characters captures and
this capture is a new move in the
position it's never been attempted
before so it is as a move 12 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
what being had in mind
see captures and now defending the
knight worked the c8 and Queen to d2
Giri develops the Queen prepares rook to
d1 and at some point he wants to push d5
of course we have each sex biding
preventing that for the moment and rook
F 2 d1 Knight to a5 offering to better
trade off a pair of rooks and ding
trades we have rook captures Queen
captures and Bishop to g5 now the idea
is that if if of course the point is
captured then Bishop
east 7 and the rook doesn't have any
squares your blacks gonna have to give
up the exchange so here ding just goes
Queen to c7 and now being starts pushing
the pawn we have d5 with this he creates
a passed pawn in chapters see sorry
capture C captures and Queen the c5 now
putting pressure on the bishop here and
the giri defends it Queen to d3 and here
Queen to b6 ding ding now blocks the
pawn here with ace Queen
but gierek just kicks it away rush up to
f4 we have Bishop to e5 and now by
trading here you will out the pawn to
start marching forward so d6 rook the d8
and now comes d7 so this is either a
very strong pawn or it's going to be a
liability later on so ding will try to
win it at all cost
so first Knight to c6 he just gets I put
I put the knight in front of the bishop
so the bishop is not defending the pawn
and he will try to put more pressure on
it we have night the sea 3 by giri and
now a6
attacking Geary's the bishop here and
here you don't really have a you don't
really have a clear way of what to do
Bishop to c4 probably then b5 then
they're back to b3 and then the game
just continues but it's hard to say now
will you be able to do something with
with this pawn of yours however Geary
played something else here here play
Bishop captures on a6 and this is a huge
problem as it blunders a piece didn't
just capture the bishop and now you're a
queen is under attack and you don't
really have much options here Geary
captured and ding just grabbed it the
night here so Geary continues with Queen
to c8 just pulling the Queen there
there's no actual threat here for the
moment since of course black will never
capture and if you capture the night
just that picks it up so Queen c2 goes
after the rook rook to e1 and now Queen
to d2 again harassing the rook we've
looked at eh check by Geary but again
King to g7 and now the problem for gear
is he can't win back his piece because
he has back rank issues now if you just
pick up the the piece here just Queen to
e1 is checkmate
so after King to geez
seven and give replayed h3 but now you
know what to do it's not enough just to
have a good position you also have to
win it so feel free to pause the video
here and try to win this game for ding
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on Rima nuvaring the
queen with checks and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
it's queen d1 check King h2 and Queen to
d6 check you used the two checks to come
back and defend the knife and now once
the King moves or g3 as was played in
the game just rook capture Sun d7 so
this is what being played and it was a
move 33 that initially resigned the game
so no no we went for a niche Giri as of
yet but the match continues we'll see
what happens in the in the games to come
so here he resigns as he's down a knight
and that's just pointless to continue
there's no way in a way to say this
better sure that's a game one of their
match I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Eric Pilkington Calahan
cocaine Robert Reaves Xavier Martin and
the and Robson for a conversion to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I'm thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day